I've always been a radical.
I've always challenged the status quo.
Do you feel like you're part
of a libertarian movement?
No, I don't, no.
So what are you then?
Well, I'm not a part of a movement.
I've never been a part of movement.
I just do my own thing.
Walter Williams, the free market scholar
and iconoclast died last
week at the age of 84.
He was the author of 13 books
and was best known for
his work demonstrating
that government interference
in the free market
has been especially
harmful to black Americans.
Born in 1936, Williams grew
up in the Richard Allen Homes,
one of Philadelphia's
first housing projects.
I broke out of the North
Philadelphia ghetto
nearly 30 years ago and
so did most of my friends.
When he was a small child,
his father deserted his family.
He was brought up by his
mother, a high school dropout,
and the family spend time on welfare
but Williams would
later draw a distinction
between material poverty
and what he called poverty of the spirit.
Even though we grew up poor,
we didn't consider ourselves
poor, that is a matter of fact.
During those days to call
somebody poor was an insult.
When I was a kid, my mother
used to always say to us,
she says, "You know, we
have a beer pocket book,
but we have champagne taste."
Williams worked as a taxi driver
in the City of Brotherly love
and was once ordered out of his cab
by a white police officer, beaten up
and then charged with disorderly conduct.
He was drafted into the army
and while stationed in Georgia
kept getting in trouble,
occasionally with his fists,
for standing up to the
racism of white officers.
But he came to believe
that discrimination should be legal,
just as long as it didn't
involve government resources.
One of my strong values
is freedom of association.
If you believe in freedom of
association, you have to accept
that people will associate in
ways that you find offensive.
And I believe people have
the right to discriminate
on any basis they want,
so long as they're not
using the government.
For me, discrimination is
just simply an act of choice.
After the army, Williams studied economics
at California State College,
and then went to UCLA for graduate school
where he was exposed to titans
of free market economics,
including Milton Friedman, James Buchanan
and UCLA's department
chair, Armen Alchian.
Flunking economic theory
the first time around,
he wrote in his memoir,
"I later realized did have a benefit.
It convinced me that UCLA professors
didn't care anything about my race.
They'd flunk me just as
they'd flunk anyone else
who didn't make it the grade."
I don't judge people by colors.
I say that well, gee,
you're a man just like I am.
And that's what my stepfather used to say.
He says, Every man stands up to piss
and he's whatever he is after that.
In 1977, Williams started writing
a weekly column which
was eventually syndicated
in 140 newspapers.
He was also a contributor
to Reason magazine
and served as a trustee on the
board of Reason Foundation,
the nonprofit that publishes Reason TV.
For all his individual accomplishments,
Williams was especially proud of his role
in making George Mason
University's economics department
a home for free market radicals.
There was considerable
hostility towards our department
and I had a lot of difficulty.
And so I just said, well,
the only way I'm gonna
improve the department
is to try to privatize the department
and actually go out and raise money.
Last week, his former colleagues
at George Mason paid tribute
to their mentor and friend.
"GMU Econ has lost an
iconic and heroic figure."
wrote Pete Boettke.
"He taught with with and passion the logic
of economic reasoning."
"He is one of my few
heroes." wrote Don Boudreaux.
Liberty is the rare state of
affairs in mankind's history.
Arbitrary abuse and control by others
is the standard dish, even now.
And all the tendencies are,
is for us to have greater
and greater amounts of our
liberty usurped by government.
Rest in peace, Walter Williams.